After September's general election, the German
conservative party was left reeling, losing
its voters to the social democrats and kingmaker
parties, the free liberals and the Greens.
Now, as the conservatives seek to redefine
themselves, women in the party want better
representation and young people are calling
for more of a say.
Here in the headquarters of the German conservative
party, behind the apparent calm, a tremor
can still be felt.
"After 16 years in power, chancellor Angela
Merkel’s party recorded its worst ever results
in September's general elections."
And despite coming second behind the social-democrats,
the CDU walks a thin line: It needs to regain
its voters' confidence.
Armin Laschet, the chancellor candidate, has
hinted at stepping down as party leader, after
a campaign marred by faux pas and gaffes for
which he apologized.
Looking ahead, younger conservatives want
to use this setback as an opportunity to renew
their party.
To begin with, some want to see more gender
parity:
"We simply have too few women in the party.
That is our job first of all, to provide more
for more women overall.
And then also of course to ensure these women
are visible and become visible."
More women, and also more space for generational
change: even seasoned conservatives are making
way for younger parliamentarians.
Defense Minister Annegret Kramp-Karrenbauer
and Economy Minister Peter Altmaier recently
renounced their Bundestag mandates to set
the pace.
"I think it's about achieving generational
change in the CDU, and I think Peter Altmaier
and Annegret Kramp-Karrenbauer have sent a
great signal to make it possible."
"If we go into opposition, it will of course
be very important that we renew ourselves
for the next federal election, and also that
generational change takes place, but I also
want to emphasize that it's not just about
lining up younger people – rather that we
need a good mix, both in the party and in
the parliamentary groups."
"Speaking about generational change, we’ve
asked younger voters what they think the conservatives
should do next."
"The youth are more oriented to the Greens
than the conservatives, so you have to look
at their motivations, what reasons they have
to prefer this party."
"I think the old-timers are still there, so
we'll have to see if they really want to give
up their power."
"It's hard to see a change taking place, or
it’s not yet quite clear that one is happening
at all."
"With a chance of playing a part in the government
lessening by the day, there will certainly
be a lot of soul searching among German conservatives
if they do indeed go into opposition."